[Musique]
des marquages au sol des sièges
d'attentes différencier ces mesures
permettent de respecter la distanciation
physique des usagers au sein de cette
maison départementale
elles font partie d'une série de règles
d'hygiène et de sécurité qui ont été
préconisées au sein de ses centres
sociaux on a travaillé aussi avec
l'agent d'entretien à la possibilité
d'être plus vigilants sur le nettoyage
sur le nettoyage aussi au quotidien et
sur la journée ici possible sur tout ce
qui est point de contact et espace
commun ainsi que les toilettes on a la
possibilité d'avoir un agent de
médiation dont qui gère le flux des
personnes qui fréquentent le service et
qui veille aussi au respect des
consignes de sécurité
par rapport aux personnes qui vont
fréquenter aussi bien partenaires que
qu'usagers les agents disposent de
masques et de solutions hydro
alcooliques pour le moment l'accueil
téléphonique des bénéficiaires est
privilégiée et en cas d'urgence
l'accueil se fera physiquement séparés
par ce cadre en plexiglas et en
respectant les gestes barrière ces
dispositifs effectivement il est adapté
lorsqu'on reçoit un usager un parce
qu'il faut que vous avez soit bien en
face arrête une mesure complémentaire de
protection pour les mêmes chaînes
projection qui pouvait se faire lors de
l' échange effectivement le la des
sensations sociale reste quand même
primordial le port du masque est très
fortement recommandée voire même
obligatoire pour les agents et usagers
ça reste un moyen complémentaire de
protection un sens de circulation ainsi
qu'une entrée et une sortie différenciée
ont été mises en place afin de limiter
les contacts physiques
toutes ces préconisations prise par la
collectivité vise avant tout à protéger
le public ainsi que les agents des
risques de contamination sanitaires liés
au virus du coït 19
[Musique]